conflicto en mariupol acaba de alcanzar
un nuevo nivel si lo consideran las
autoridades ucranianas por primera vez
las fuerzas rusas atacaron con tanques y
vehículos blindados la siderúrgica de as
hostal también se informó que los
soldados han intentado desembarcar
utilizando botes de infantería hasta
ahora el ejército ruso bombardeo la
fábrica usando aviones y desde el mar un
cambio de estrategia que se explica por
el comportamiento del regimiento a soft
la milicia nacionalista que forma el
grueso de las tropas ucranianas aún
atrincheradas y que según el ministerio
de defensa ruso aprovechó el alto el
fuego para salir del sótano de la planta
siderúrgica y posicionarse alrededor del
edificio la milicia ha difundido vídeos
que muestran a las víctimas de los
bombardeos durante la noche
estas dos chicas estaban en la cocina no
había soldados no había miembros de soft
nos estábamos preparando para la
evacuación
así que la pesadilla continúa para unos
200 civiles que siguen refugiados en el
sótano del complejo metalúrgico
según el alcalde de mariupol este fin de
semana por primera vez en dos meses de
asedio y bomba y un centenar de civiles
fueron evacuados algunos de ellos
llegaron a la cercana ciudad de sap
orilla bajo control ucraniano a pesar de
la escalada de violencia el presidente
de ucrania espera continuar con la
evacuación
sin duda seguiremos haciendo todo lo que
esté en nuestras manos para sacar a toda
nuestra gente de mariupol sea soft tal
es difícil pero necesitamos a todo el
mundo a todos los que siguen allí
civiles y militares
la onu espera poder organizar más
evacuaciones humanitarias de parte de la
población en mariupol incluidas las
personas que necesitan atención médica